hi and welcome to episode number 30 of
the weekly Google club pass on podcast i
am francisco and i'm here with Mark
Mundell my colleague hey how are you
doing a friend asked how you feeling
you've been on a bit of a long journey
yeah a little bit sore you know like
biking 600 miles apparently get let
makes you tired it's weird you're new
yeah who knew very happy to be sitting
on chairs that is lovely that's slightly
bigger than the one on might be on my
bike yes very happy about that and
today's episode 30 which is pretty good
number yeah are very very big number 30
already I'm proud of you manage done a
good job yeah you too thank you not as
good as mine but pretty good thanks I'll
check i'll bring my game up every yeah
and and to celebrate that we have
episode number 30 we're actually
bringing not one not two but three
guests today it's crazy yeah so we're
gonna have three different product
managers actually two product managers
and one technical program manager so
cute etfs key from google cloud pub/sub
eric anderson from google cloud dataflow
and tina teresh cure from Google
bigquery and we're going to be talking
about basically how you can do big data
and knowledge analytics for mobile yeah
so there's actually a gaming solution
that you could probably apply to several
other things that website that we can go
to and we're going to step through that
and so look at all the different pieces
that are enable that and no I should use
those so we're going to be talking a lot
up a big data during the main content
but also there in the question of the
week the question of the week is going
to be about bigquery but before we even
start with those we have the cool thing
of the week and guess what it is about
bigquery too it's another big query
point yes nice big query everywhere and
and I'm actually pretty excited about
this one because I used to do a lot of a
lot of sequel and as you might know the
Google bigquery supported a dialect of
sequel that was very similar to sequel
but there was some slight differences
well the latest version has started our
sequel now so if you know sequel it's
you just know be quite now so that is
pretty cool that is pretty
I know when I was using it like
especially like things are out joins and
stuff like that and you try and do it
and then you like I can't and then you'd
read the docs in there like oh just add
this extra special little thing that's
just extra special yeah and if you
didn't know what it was your kind of
stock so now everything is just standard
sequel which is great I'm very sorry
about that there's also a support for I
am so we did an F is another long ago
about it identity and access management
so you have a finer control on who can
access and who can do what bigquery and
then you were pretty excited about the
last one the time-based table
partitioning yeah so you no longer have
to actually manually span out you're
like partition say like this is like
January state of februari et cetera
bigquery is going to do that for you out
of the box which just means it's a
little less work that you need to do yep
and less work is always better yes cool
the episode today it's gonna be kind of
long so why don't we go and talk
directly to our friends from the big
data sounds good to me cool we are
joined today by three product managers
talking about gaming analytics platform
we are joined by cute ETFs key Erik
Anderson and teen 1802 resco I think I
got that vaguely right was that that
vaguely close they got it excellent
almost people uh-huh I'm pretty excited
because this is the most number of
people we've been interviewing on the
podcast ever so it's going to be very
interesting but I think it's gonna it's
going to go pretty well so before we get
stuck sort of into the meat of it why
don't we sort of get you all to tell us
all a little about yourselves i'm going
to go based on the order that i have in
the document so care do you want to go
first tell us a little about yourself in
who you are hi there i am cured to TF
ski and i'm the product manager for
Google cloud pub/sub I want me trying to
figure out how exactly to explain why
I'm excited about it and it finally
struck me today it's that it made
networking a synchronous it's fast but
it's a synchronous you know how when the
first the first kind of network you
could just call somebody you can call
somebody on the phone and if they were
there you could have a synchronous
conversation
and if they were not there you were
stuck now email came along and it made
that whole thing a synchronous right he
could just instantly shoot somebody an
email or an instant message and it was
there if they if they're on the other
side and a second if they're not they
could wait for them for days pub/sub did
the same thing for just general
networking shipping data around so
that's that's what I'm excited about
cool and what is your location right now
I just curious about how many people in
different places we have oh this is
exciting we're I think I think we've got
the entire country represented with the
quarters right I'm in New York today
cool cool all right Eric how about
yourself sure I'm Eric Anderson I'm a
product manager on data flow this is if
it's interesting I've been at Google for
three years now start on a little data
science team have been a data flow for
maybe a year and a half let's see i'm
based normally mountain view on my way
to New York first some conferences and
currently in salt lake city utah cool
excellent aunty know yourself either um
Tino to rush go I'm a technical program
manager for bigquery which is a google
serverless fully managed petabyte scale
analytics data warehouse a bit queries
used widely at Google across all of the
Google's organizations and we have lots
of really exciting customers to speak of
as well and I'm based out of Seattle
I've been at Google for almost three
years and I did on the bigquery team for
about a year cool so then yeah and then
we are here in San Francisco San
Francisco Seattle sonic New York in salt
lake city was it yes right there we go
you left the coasts Eric you left the
coasts no it's like almost like a
layover in between them though yeah I'll
be there shortly very cool and we have
then
we have pops up we have data flow and we
have bigquery what are the relationship
across all of them yeah so I'm we're
here sort of talk about sort of a
reference implementation we've had on
the website for a while so we're not
building a mobile gaming analytics
platform which is a solution people can
go online will have the link in the show
notes for people available do one of you
three want to volunteer to sort of talk
about what this is and how it works it
seems to kind of cut across all three of
your segments sure I'll go first and you
guys tell me when I get things wrong
that's good this is care so the the
reason I got excited about doing this
particular this particular pod cast
aside from being a loyal listener is is
that I recently heard the the interview
you guys did with it with the gaming
company it was war of dragons right yep
yeah yes and they were talking about
their pipeline which looked very much
like our reference diagram which you can
find on the Google cloud site which
looks something like this for for those
of you who are not looking at the
website we're listening it's it's a
client be it on your mobile phone or not
talking to a front end server and then
needing to hand over the data for
processing to a set of three things you
push your pushy event data to cloud
pub/sub which then gets pulled into data
flow which where it gets transformed or
it gets massaged where you get where you
enrich your data or strip what you don't
need and then you finally put it on the
results in bigquery that's sort of a
standard stack this just to just before
you go any further you want to take a
step back and say like what sort of data
or we take talking about here the
reference is mobile gaming analytics but
like can you give people sort of an
example of what sort of data would be
ingesting oh absolutely and by the way i
highly recommend those of you who are
listening to go back I think it'd be two
or three episodes to hear a very
detailed account of how this works for
this for for war of dragons but you're
just talking about user events right
whenever somebody finds that coin kills
the dragon you know their score go
is up they bought something as a mobile
app developer or mobile game developer
in particular you are interested in
understanding how these events tied
together so you can start optimizing a
game right so you're looking for those
gems gems of little interactions of work
or those that slow down your users in in
a way this is sort of the same story
that that you might be working on if you
are just optimizing a site right you
think Google Analytics right for game
developers this is especially important
because it's such a dynamic and
competitive field that you have to
really understand exactly what the users
are doing at any point of the game cool
so all right so you've got a bunch of
game data coming in players doing stuff
maybe beating bosses or levels and stuff
and you need a way to ingest that and
then send that on somewhere else right
ultimately you want to make sure that
that the game developers and the data
scientists on the team who oftentimes
are the same person sometimes not
depending on how big the company is can
actually make sense of this data and so
I think bigquery is the thing that makes
it possible to to to examine these vast
volume of data quickly but upstream so
that the combination of cloud pub/sub
and data flow are the things that that
make it possible to ingest the data and
transform it as its streaming cool so
all right so it sounds like looking at
the diagram the first step is pub/sub so
my question is okay why pops up why why
is this wise is the first step so you
can think of pub sub as as another
solution for logging all right if you
think about sort of the old school way
of doing things right here your lamp
stack back in the day every time you get
a web request and you would respond to
the user and dump a record to your to
system log or Apache log or wherever you
have we had you set up done and so then
you might go and you would have a
subsystem that would trawl through the
logs put them in some kind of ETL loop
and every so often you would just sort
of ingest the log
put it into my sequel database and then
and then somebody on the other on the
other end would go and look at the data
to try to figure out what's happening
the what's what's happened as we went
away from doing having single stacks
right to having multiple servers or
microservices implementing many of many
of the applications especially games
because they're so vastly distributed
right as soon as you start talking about
players talk players playing in
different sides of the country if Eric
and I were playing today we'd have to
somehow communicate and synchronize
things between a server that's close to
Utah and a server that's close to to New
York City you dealing with a system
that's not a single stack right
something is far away from that disk so
how do you get how do you have a
solution that looks a little bit like
just very quickly writing to log so that
you can process these event data late
later but that works for a completely
distributed set of micro services or
just just servers and that's pub/sub
pub/sub is I don't know a silly example
is no it's like it's like email for it's
like email or instant messaging for four
machines instead of writing to log any
machine anywhere in the world can just
put a message on pub/sub and say hey I
play just killed the dragon done from
there on the front ends can focus on
servicing the users and the backends can
just read those messages from pub sub 2
to figure out what to do with them cool
so you mentioned a couple times the
three magic words etl i could you
explain a little bit what those are what
that means for for our audience I'm glad
that you consider that you consider etl
the magic words risk egg do you want to
take this one on since you're not sure
yeah yeah so yeah so commonly this is
just extract transform load so you've
got data in point a and you want to move
it to point B not maybe maybe move it
may be
you're just looking to change it and
change data is often immutable and so
changing involving involves moving but
yeah so you're going from in this case
pub/sub the big crate you're going to
extract it from pub/sub transform it and
load it into bigquery butBut etl is is
Trish initely more often used when
you're you know moving database to
database or our final system the
database anytime you move date around
cool so in this case we could say that
the e neat al could be cloud tops up
that's how you're extracting that
information from all the other data
sources that's right cool and what
happens next so yeah so this dismissing
the data flow um and and that this is
the Chi in ETL we're going to transform
the data you know you might be asking
yourself why are we transforming the
data um there's a lot of things that we
could do here in data flow you might be
we mentioned enriching the data so you
have events from raw events from user
you may just want to add a location that
is found elsewhere you have the IP
address of the client you could
transform that now into a geographical
location you could be joining the data
against databases that you have to to
pull an additional user data to add more
color to your vengeful analysis a lot of
people are doing schema transformations
another situation you may hit is if
you've got old clients running some
version of the game you have newer
clients running another version of the
game they're sending different kinds of
events you could normalize those schemas
and data flow so that everything that
hits bigquery is in the shape you expect
and the shape it's easy to analyze so I
guess those are a few examples of what
you're doing a data flow cool so that
means that basically a cloud dataflow at
what it's doing is just doing those
transformations to be able to dance
store it in some nice way that you might
be interested what is cloud dataflow
exactly yeah so data flow is a stream
and batch data processing
service it's also a programming model
and instead of SDKs that programming
model and SDKs were recently submitted
to Apache and now refer to as Apache
beam it's an incubating project but we
can get into more that later but the
service itself is a as I said batch and
string processing engine you describe
currently in Java very soon in Python
the transformations you want to apply on
data you describe also the sources is
you're going to pull from and where
you're going to sink or persist the data
when the transformations are over and
this in the case of java jar file is is
sent to the service and the service
itself spins up virtual machines in
google cloud and and manages all the
complexities of distributed computing
that are going on there and including
ensuring correctness of and fault
tolerance and then once that data's all
persisted to your storage system in this
case bigquery we tear down the VMS tear
down the job and report to you all the
logs and statistics that happened during
the process so is it like my previous
yeah yeah I could have started there is
so this is this is Google's MapReduce
system and also a more recent stream
processing system mill will combined um
under a single SDK yeah what's really
cool about it is that this is care in
New York again is it I feel like it
works the same way whether it's pulling
a single event off pub/sub or if you're
doing two million QPS all right it's you
basically just define a single
transformation in many cases if you're
just looking at a single event at a time
right you don't even have to know how
many events you're going to process
right the pub the data flow just
abstracts all of that for you is that
right Eric yes totally and and maybe
taking that even further there is some
really
part of the reason we went have a
building data flow because there is
existing alternatives you know in the
marketplace is look the Holy Grail
particularly with this gaming setup is
recreating the session Ike you have all
these complex events coming in from
users all over the place in different
situations they all fled the system and
and making sense of a bat and aggregate
is really tricky data flow has built-in
primitives to recreate sessions and
allow you to analyze sessions which is
typically ultimately what people are
after here we move events from out of
order and to in order within data flow
and and then once they're in order we
then can apply windowing strategies we
call them to group those events in this
case i mentioned sessions would be
really useful but yeah you can group
them by a user session and then perform
some analytic function on that user
session like like you know what happened
after this event or how many of these
events happened what's the average of
those events and then that can help then
be sent and persisted to bigquery yeah
I'm happy to add my thoughts on this so
this is tino from the bigquery team what
data flow allows you to do and pops up
of course as well is it really changed
the model of how developers look at
their game data do instead of collecting
kind of summary events things like I
just picked up a sword or things like I
just killed a boss instead of kind of
choosing which events you want to you
want to collect and analyze at a future
date this kind of daisy chain of
services allows you to look at
everything have a holistic view of your
data and that really allows you to
analyze your gaming from very very
different angles than ever before
possible and the second thing that it
allows you to do is imagine what the
maps space was before ways came along
before ways if you had a section of the
road and you wanted to figure out what
was the traffic pattern on that road on
friday between
five and six of like an evening you'd
have to run a sequel query and say oh
well generally at that period is 15
miles an hour all right let's paint the
red now with ways you have a real time
processing engine that collects the data
pushes it to the CTO pipeline and feeds
it back into the application and so now
with ways we know right this moment that
is a green section of the road and you
can do the same thing with gaming right
you can exhaust how your games work by
feeding the data directly back into the
game itself which really unlocks a lot
of possibilities for game developers yes
you can really kind of adjust your
gameplay on the fly depending on what
events are happening inside that game
exactly exactly excellent okay and there
we've got we've got to the e in the tea
why don't we talk a little bit about the
l i'm guessing the Elven is bigquery
would that be correct um the l i would
in my opinion the l is the the result of
loading data into the bigquery and once
data is loaded in the bigquery hopefully
prepare then and clean and nice to look
at you're able to analyze that data
through kind of any pure ad hoc data
scientist exploration mode right you
don't have to plan how you want to
analyze the data in bigquery it gives
you the freedom to look at your data in
any way imaginable right you can look at
historical data going back several years
you can look at data in real time that
gets fed through the query through data
phone pops up and you can look at
massive massive amounts of data right so
this this holistic raw data viewpoint is
really enabled by the query you can stop
tourists so I think you're talking about
the fourth step there's a letter that we
have missed it should be either p or mp4
profit or m4 magic I don't know which
what it is but I think but I think it
speaks to the point that it's not just
about loading right it's it's about it's
about being able to make sense of the
data in the same place where you just
keep it where you keep the result yep
that's exactly it and the chorea doesn't
require you to think very hard about
whether you have keys or indexes or what
your data sets are too big you just slow
you that into bigquery and you use plain
regular standard sequel to analyze it
right um and because the court doesn't
require you to stand up massive amounts
of infrastructure to leverage massive
amounts of infrastructure for your
analysis you the doors really open up
right you can do a whole lot um very
very quickly with the query actually
that's that's a point that they could be
made about 03 / 03 of the tools we're
talking about here I think we're we're
kind of in this in this nice in this
nice level of Google Cloud which is
managed services right neither pub/sub
nor data flow or bigquery require you to
provision much all right they just their
services they just run right if you
think about doing etl in a traditional
way you have to think about the physical
machines where this happens I still I
still vividly remember once
decommissioning decommissioning a
mainframe it was a fun adventure of it
with moving with moving a box on wheels
and several people from from a data
center into truck like that was you know
you don't even have to think about that
anymore in principle right that's just
which is which in my my my head is
magical in all three of the steps but in
bigquery in particular I don't know if
yeah you you bring up a really good
point um but there's this new buzzword
that's coming around it's actually an
old password but it's it's seen its it's
become reinvented called serverless
right you you see in this with google
cloud functions and a doll us lambda but
service generally applies to really tiny
load jobs that get executed without
having to stand up a cluster pops up
data flow by Corey is serverless big
data you're able to analyze the data at
scale um and in any way you want in real
time without standing up servers right
server let's big data is really a
reality today with these services great
yeah just to recap on some of that a
little bit as well just it sounds like
the combination of the three is
exceptionally powerful
and it sounds like so pub/sub for
ingesting messages at scale data flow
for handling stuff in real time like
even even for transformations but also
like analyzing gameplay and whatnot and
then bigquery for maybe more after the
fact sort of what do we what do we were
can we find out that we don't already
think we know or go exploring with would
any of you sort of agree with that yes
certainly I you've described have to two
ways of stacking these 11 and these are
the ones that Tino brought up already we
could ingest data applied
transformations in real time and data
flow and then feed that back into the
game loop or we can also then and no or
but in addition to we could push that to
bigquery and persisted for for soon and
in future analysis totally thinking back
to it sort of my days as a data
scientist in in ads which is its own
kind of game I used to work and building
recommendation engines for ads what what
practically happens right for you as a
data scientist which would be kind of
the type of user oftentimes who is
sitting in front of a big query
interface and and you're you don't know
sort of you doing ad hoc way and you're
trying to your testing hypotheses very
quickly and as you find things at work
you practically push them up the stack
right you go and talk to the engineers
who write data flow code the right once
you find that that the right combination
of sort of levers that need to be pulled
and you start implementing the things
that came out of you I ad hoc wearing in
data flow you know or if you're not on
data flow of course you're you're going
for whatever it is your ad hoc ad hoc
solution is to to wherever it is that
your live code is running cool so I was
actually just thinking so say I am a
game developer or some sort of
application developer with a lot of
interface interaction and a lot of data
coming through and I want to implement
this strategy should I start by working
on say the pub sub end should I start by
just implementing bigquery and something
getting data into that or like how much
of this should I try and take you when
we go was what's the easiest step sugar
bigquery then maybe a data flow down in
line and then pops up down the line or
should I start with pub/sub what's that
what's my was my entry point here I I'm
sure you all have different will have
yeah but we'll give you three different
entry points and i would say i would say
for a game developer um he it really
very much depends on where your data is
today um if you're like many game
developers using App Engine for
front-end you have a fantastic option
which is which is just cloud logging you
can say you can import or export rather
all of you logs directly from App Engine
into bigquery or pub/sub and so I would
say there again depending on how you're
writing your logs you should start with
bigquery because when you don't know
exactly what you're trying to implement
you should you should start with the ad
hoc solution look at all of your logs
see what you can find out the when he
export for all logs you have an ability
to to analyze them very quickly but
because the scheme are not applied
because you're not enriching the data
you're not necessarily getting the the
best out of the data or your workflow is
not necessarily great it's a bit of a
pain and so if you get to a place as I'm
sure you will where you are seeing some
return on that work we use we're
starting to get some insights about what
the users are doing right the swords are
good pick axes are not so good right
right that that's why you need to you
know that's what you need to go to to to
the cloud console and say hey now let's
let's let's try this this data flow and
pub/sub thing so you can start
publishing your logs to pub sub and then
from there bringing up data flow job to
analyze them transform them apply the
schema and go to bigquery I think you
know your third step might be okay now
that you've sort of taken stuff that
you've been dumping two logs and put it
through this pipeline you got
uncomfortable you can start publishing
instead of you know writing two logs and
I'm sort of recovering then data from
Google Cloud logging you may just
publish directly to pub sub that's a
possibility
I think a very exciting entry point for
for some of the game developers and
maybe and maybe for web site and
services developers actually really
anybody who uses who uses google google
analytics right there's another direct
entry point with bigquery is it right
Tina I was talking about the the the
export that's sort of that there's a one
flavor which we get all of your data
already parsed and nicely packaged how
does that work yes there's a google
xperia ms a enterprise-level offering of
google analytics and it comes with a
daily bigquery experts it was pretty
sweet i used it i used it for the last
android app we develop where we
instrumented the app to report all the
events wasn't a game it wasn't a game it
was an app for booking rooms but it was
pretty sweet to just just have all that
data in bigquery immediately without any
intermediate steps yeah I think a lot of
the gaming companies that we see start
it's a big query so easy to use and so
easy to get started with we even have
public data sets in the query that you
don't even need to know sequel to start
using them we pre-built dashboards for
our for our customers to you to look at
it's so easy to get started with the
query and that's you know it helps you
understand the shape of your data very
very quickly in a very ad hoc fashion
it's the folks generally try bigquery
first and then as their pipelines mature
as they want to go more real-time is
they want to enrich the data or create
that feedback loop they start
implementing inevitably data flow and
pops up into that equation as well
that's my ticket and I think what's
interesting about what we've said so far
about how you you set up these pipelines
initially and grow them is there's no
throwaway code there's no decision that
says oh this is how you prototype and
then once you reach scale you have to
throw that all away and then you do this
other way which is much more complicated
and has fewer features but but it can
handle the scale you need well um the
way you have your pipeline
scale or or or for prototype is the same
and it's in both cases it's fairly
straightforward going going back to what
Kyra said about starting out with like
logs in bigquery or or a pub sub
pipeline in either case data flow logic
can be reused so you can write a batch
job on your big query log export and
then once you've pipe that into pub/sub
you can apply that same logic it's the
same code to the streaming pipeline also
data flow comes with a local running
solution so if you want to mess on your
laptop from a pub sub or from bigquery
that same same experience works there
locally and then you just push it to the
cloud for the scale runs cool all right
so unfortunately this is a great
conversation but we are running at a
time just a little bit I'll go through
each of you if there's anything we
haven't covered and I'm sure there's a
lot but you want to sort of highlight or
plug please feel free to do so and then
I think we're going to have to wrap up
unfortunately going by order of
appearance at here did you want to go
first no I don't want this to end but
too much fun though but I I'll say this
i think i think the the this notion that
there is a service that allows you to
connect things in the cloud right and
just it will it will work like a logging
system where you just dump messages into
it and they can be recovered at any
point anywhere in the world is is a
pretty amazing is a pretty amazing
prospect for me and you know just in
general the pub sub the pub sub paradigm
in itself is is pretty cool once you
start getting into the distributed
distributed computing site of computing
which is which is everything today and
in cloud pub/sub that's just kind of
delivered to you on a silver platter it
just kind of works so i think i would i
would encourage i would encourage game
developers and really anybody who is who
is in
stating collecting data from from their
mobile apps or website apps to think
about how all the data from from the
different endpoints and the different
services comes together right it's it's
not just plain networking anymore you
gotta have something a little fancier
excellent and Eric sure thanks for
having me this is um I'm very excited to
see what what these game developers do
when you have time to devote to actually
develop in your game and getting
insights from your data and not standing
up distributed analytical pipeline
systems and babysitting clusters I think
awesome things happen so thanks for
having us and I'm excited to see what
people build excellent and finally Tina
yeah thanks for having me guys I will
add that if folks want to find out more
about what's possible I would encourage
you to look at a YouTube video of the
Google cloud platform next the which is
a conference that we had in March one of
our awesome customers Kabam games they
make Marvel games and fast and furious
games they spent about 25 minutes
discussing how they're using bigquery
and all the other services do we have
and it's really really interesting use
case they discover how folks make import
in game purchase decisions what about a
where is the most fraud comes from or if
they introduce bosses that are
overpowering how do they discover that
how to understand when their
imperfections in their games and
potentially what's even more interesting
is that Kabam games launches a lot of
titles and they're not sure when some of
these titles can be small or very very
successful and the query data form
pub/sub allows them to not think about
scale right they built the same way for
one customer as they do for 10 million
customers that's a great luxury for a
game developer excellent great well
thank you so much to the three of you
for taking the time to share that very
interesting conversation with us thank
you Mark thank you for in sisk thank you
thank you very alright please cheers
Cheers have a good one thank you again
to cure Eric and
you know for such a such an interesting
conversation I learned a lot about it
and I hope that you got excited about
the whole idea of putting those three
different products together to basically
understand better what your application
and people are doing with your
applications yeah now I really actually
liked it I learned a lot particularly
about data flow I hadn't really thought
about what was possible in terms of the
transformation aspect of it yeah I found
that particularly interesting yeah very
excited let's see some of our listeners
I have some similar story had they're
using it maybe you can send us a little
bit about how you doing it or your
questions and comments about it we're
looking forward to that as always
absolutely and why don't we go with the
question of the week yeah so this is I
think an interesting one especially
based on sort of what we're talking
about today looking at bigquery and it
maybe it's something that you want to
play with but you don't have maybe a big
data set of your own maybe yeah you're
like I don't you know I don't have just
terabytes of data lying around it's not
something I generally do so are their
data sets available to me that I can
just get in and play with and see the
power of bigquery and see whether it's a
really good fit for me yeah and the
answer obviously is yes I mean you think
these for demos because it is pretty
cool you can basically just go there and
start running queries on huge data sets
and we have a link on the show notes to
that data set it's somewhere like
cloud.google.com / peak where / public
data it's pretty close something like
that and you will see that we have a
bunch of them there's like us a name so
you can see all the different names and
from the birth that occurred in the
united states since 1879 which has been
quite a while so you can i do analysis
egg what was the most common name for
doing a year or in the 90s or whatever
you can totally do that it's very easy
there's also some others that are
actually surprisingly surprisingly
interesting like we have all the
comments all the stories and comments
from hacker news from 2006 so you can do
a lot of really cool analysis based on
that I know that the demo from
from next use these data set to create
things like in what what primary
language people curse most and things
like that like there was hacker news
there was I don't know if github is here
there is some data different github I
definitely saw that yeah so anyway
there's a bunch of different different
data sets and you can definitely check
them out the good thing is that you're
going to be able to click there and then
go directly to the bigquery console
where you can start running your queries
and you can do up to what is it a
terabyte of processing for free yeah I
think it's a either a terabyte or five
terabytes I don't remember right now but
it's it's a lot of data yeah so you can
totally do that so it gives you a good
chance to really play with it get your
feet wet and maybe you probably find
some interesting things happening in
some big data sets I'm seeing there's a
data set here for dota 2 i'm kind of
curious to see what's in there hmm well
excellent France s thank you very much
for joining me yet again this week thank
you Mark uh and I guess that since it's
episode 30 and we haven't known you for
quite a while should we bring should we
remind people where they can get in
contact with us exactly what I was
trying yeah you know bicycling for a
long time it's okay I understand so yeah
so we have a web page gcp podcast comp
and not only that but cloud or gold come
/ podcast now yeah yes yes oh geez
blockers to come we are on twitter at
GCT podcast on reddit at / r / gcp
podcast on google plus at plus gcp
podcast and i think that's it on slack
Oh your hatch podcast and also they can
contact a spam email hello at gcb
podcast.com great well looking forward
to all of your messages regarding these
episodes and others and talk to you all
next week see you next week
you